مشاهد عرضتها الفضائيات،
وأبكت العرب من الشرق إلى الغرب،
جنود المارينز يتجولون في بغداد بدلا عن الجيش العراقي،..
وهنا تتبادر إلى الذهن عدد من الأسئلة..
أين ذهب جيش صدام؟
كيف اختفى أقوى جيش عربي
وأحد أقوى الجيوش في العالم؟
ما الذي حدث ليلة سقوط بغداد؟
فجأة اختفى كل شيء في العراق
فلا حرس جمهوري ولا ترسانة أسلحة
ولا حتى أفراد من الجيش،
فجأة سقطت بغداد دون مقاومة
وسقط معها تمثال صدام حسين من منصة الفردوس وسط بغداد،
وبدأت السرقة والنهب من جميع المؤسسات الحكومية...
(للتوضيح أكثر تابعوا معنا دقائق هذا لفيديو) ...
عندما بدأت معركة المطار
كانت هي المعركة الفاصلة في الحرب.. ،
غير أنه سبقها ظهور بوادر تململ
في صفوف الجيش العراقي في البصرة،
حيث عمد بعض كبار الضباط
إلى تصرفات تهدف إلى التخلص من الفدائيين والمتطوعين العرب.
وحينما تم الإنزال الأمريكي في مطار صدام الدولي،
امتنع الحرس الجمهوري عن التوجه للقتال في المطار،
ما دفع الرئيس صدام حسين إلى قيادة إحدى كتائب الحرس شخصيا،
مستقلا الدبابة الأولى التي هاجمت القوات الأمريكية في المطار
مسنوداً بقوات المتطوعين العرب والفدائيين،
حيث تمكن بهذه القوات من قتل العشرات من الجنود الأمريكيين
قبل انسحابهم، رغم أن طيران الجيش امتنع عن توفير غطاء جوي له.
وبدلا من أن ترتفع المعنويات بدأ فصل جديد من المؤامرة
تمثل في ازدياد كثافة عمليات انزال أعداد محدودة
من الدبابات الأمريكية داخل مواقع متعددة في بغداد،
وانزالِ أفراد معارضة عراقية بواسطة المروحيات الأمريكية،
وقد جيئة بهم من خارج العراق ليقوموا بإلقاء الورود على المحتلين
ونهب المؤسسات العامة بدءا من الثامن من إبريل
بهدف خلخلة الجبهة الداخلية للعراق.
أما الجيش، وكذلك الحرس الجمهوري
فلم يخوضا المعركة الاستراتيجية في بغداد:
وقد بدأ التلاعب في البصرة..،
وفي إحدى المواجهات التي وقعت في البصرة،
كان هنالك ثلاثة من الفدائيين العرب
واثنان من العراقيين هوجموا وتمت السيطرة عليهم
وأسرُهم من قبل القوات الأمريكية.
وعندها خاطب أحد الفدائيين ضابطا في الجيش العراقي متسائلا
( كيف يأسرون رفاقنا وحنا نتفرج..؟!
جاوبه الضابط: ما عليك)..!
عندها قام الفدائي بإطلاق الرصاص من رشاشه على السيارة الأمريكية
التي كانت تقل الفدائيين الخمسة كأسرى،
ما أدى إلى انقلابها.
وتم تحرير الأسرى وانضم المقاتلون العراقيون
إلى الفدائي العربي وحرروا الفدائيين الأسرى،
وقتلوا الجنود الأمريكان الذين كانوا قد أسروا الفدائيين".
يقول مسؤول سابق في حزب البعث :
" فجأة، اختفى الحرس الجمهوري الذي كان متحصنا في البساتين،
وذلك جراء تعليمات من قادة الصف الأول في الحرس،
إلى قادة الصف الثاني،
أن أبلغوا أفراد الحرس بأنه كي نتمكن من تنظيم المواجهة
في معركة مفتوحة طويلة الأمد،
فإن أفضل ما يمكن فعله الآن هو الاختفاء".
بالتزامن مع ذلك تم ترويج شائعة تقول
أن صدام حسين قد قتل الى أن ظهر يوم 8 إبريل
في الوزيرية والكاظمية،
وظهر لهم ثانية في اليوم التالي في شارع 14 رمضان،
لكن حالة التململ التي بدأت في الصف القيادي الأول في البصرة
انتقلت إلى بغداد، ما تسبب بالسقوط السريع لبغداد".
وأكدت رغد صدام حسين أن خيانة المقربين لصدام
من قادة الجيش كانت من أهم الأسباب لهذا السقوط السريع للقوات،
بقولها ("سقوط بغداد كان صدمة كبيرة جدا كان واضحا للأسف
أن الأشخاص الذين وضع فيهم الرئيس ثقته المطلقة
كانت الخيانة الأساسية منهم. هذا تخاذل،
الرجل يمكن أن لا يحبك لكن لن يغدر بك، الغدر ليس من شيم العرب".)
كانت تلك أبرز أسباب سقوط جيش صدام
فضلا عن استخدام الجيش الأمريكي للقنابل المحرمة دوليا
التي تقتل البشر وتحرق الأجساد تماما لكنها تبقي الأسلحة والأبنية سليمة..
والجيش الأمريكي استخدم أيضا في معركة المطار قنابل تزن تسعة أطنان
وقنابل فوسفورية حارقة قادرة على إحراق منطقة عمليات
بحجم سرية إضافة إلى عوامل تشل القدرة.
غموض سقوط جيش صدام، واختفائه فجأة
جعل منه موضوعا يثير تساؤلات الغرب قبل العرب،
فهل كانت هذه هي الأسباب الحقيقة لاختفاء الجيش
أم أن هناك أسباباً وعوامل أخرى؟
ضعوا آراءكم في التعليقات.